what's up reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we are gonna watch the
trailer for a Midway Roland Emmerich's
newest film I think there was a trailer
that came out a while ago but
unfortunately it did not catch that one
so I figured it's best to catch this one
and also tell you guys I'm going on
phantom entertainment screen junkies
news in just a little bit 11:00 a.m.
Pacific Standard Time anywho let's hop
right into this shall we
it was just the usual
Oh
[Music]
Pearl Harbor is the greatest
intelligence failure in American history
never
and a lot of other movies I'm gonna make
your brain
Nick Jonas
[Music]
so what's the target
we believe it's Midway Washington
disagrees
who washed it this time weapon he's on
the west coast Seattle San Francisco Los
Angeles
[Music]
I know what it feels like
[Music]
but a couple different place
it's all Japanese sleep
this is apparently
[Music]
[Music]
you know that you came to
[Music]
to that real yeah I thought that was
Darren Criss
damn
-
oh I wonder how how real veterans feel
about a trailer like this no promise
soon and they're cheering it on Oh in
hell yeah exactly how I felt like a cool
action movie when I was there yeah yeah
yeah with some historical context just
to remind us all
I like Roland Emmerich's movies for the
most part I'm gonna acknowledge that a
lot of them aren't exactly great film
but nine times out of 10 I'm usually
having fun when I'm watching it even if
it's a movie like 2012 or Day Afternoon
one of his many disaster movies
I even prefer White House down over
Olympus has fallen so I'm by no stretch
a roland emmerich hater even though I
can acknowledge he is not one of the
most credible artistic filmmakers out
there but he usually has an amount of
good cheesy heart some epic scale action
sequences a good ensemble of character
actors and that's what he's doing here
just with a true story
you know everything we've seen him do
with his big disaster movies is all
right here on display I feel like I
should be feeling something along the
lines of what that
19:50 know trailer made me feel
something that felt a little bit more
harrowing and despairing no feelings
that war movies ought to give you and in
here I instead was like oh awesome yeah
look at all that CGI action going on
cool you know it's a lots of that demand
for a film to do this all practical but
I don't know how much of this is
practical and then they CGI'd over it to
fine-tune some stuff but it looks like
most of it is CGI I mean a lot of the
action looks CGI or green-screen or
enhanced or yeah you have so many of
these incredible destruction shots of
like planes flipping over and crashing
into battleships and stuff so I would
expect I guess that only like the
establishing shots and the quieter
moments on these aircraft carriers or
whatever are gonna be practical I mean
this to me looks like hurl Harbor
knowing better what kind of movie it
truly wants to be sure without any
illusion too much of a love story other
than that one see it almost
this look like there's one scene or
there's gonna be a character moment
between ed skrein and his lady companion
I think that was Mandy Moore Oh was that
man anymore oh wow that's cool famously
starring in 47 meters down oh yeah her
Nick Jonas man finally together on
screen I hope they do a song for the end
credit you know I always laugh when I
see Nick Jonas appear in something but
then whenever I watch him in something
he's pretty good well this is the kind
of movie or that seems to be appropriate
you know just because like Harry Styles
wasn't done correctly so no Nick Jonas
I'm here and then you got Michael Bay
doing Pearl Harbor who's next in line to
do a Pearl Harbor s kind of film other
than rollin Emery yeah and maybe he this
one will say you mean a more solid
all-around experience perhaps yeah I
don't know I think that you could have
done something with this subject matter
that could have been a little bit more
impactful I know I'm talking as if I've
seen the movie already it's weighing in
what this Lionsgate line is gaining
Sonya when I watch one of their trailers
even if I'm like optimistic oh and I
hope it's not like that usually is what
it is yeah when I watch the movie I mean
I expected this to have some broad
strokes about you know it's yams in
heroism and the triumph of the human
spirit thing was on I could get on board
with cheese
I can't even even in a war movie I can
get on board with cheesiness I get on
board with over exuberant amounts of all
Sarge I just wish that you know when you
got these amount of actors ed skrein
Patrick Luke Evans Woody Harrelson yeah
you got these this great ensemble of
Awesome actors in here and I kind of
feel like they're just names and a
voiceover class for an animator
credibility the actors you know showing
up to bring their clout to their
different military posts and whatnot
like that's kind of I guess you could
call that stunt casting because it's
like okay you know these guys you know
Woody Harrelson or Aaron Eckhart like
those guys who are a little you know
they've got that presents you know
they're perfect to play these military
mind types yeah
just looks like another it does it looks
exactly I just hope it has some of that
unintentional humor that roland emmerich
constantly manages though ring out oh
yeah this and if it's in a war movie
perfect I would love that I find it
funny that line that Patrick Wilson says
about Washington is wrong oh yeah I
think you could have made this movie
twenty years ago thirty years ago ten
years ago whatever but I imagine that
with that line now with the current
political climate the hue s is in people
might totally read into that in a
completely different kind of context for
this part of art of the advertising yeah
I'm curious about that I mean to me
coming from this kind of movie coming
from this kind of filmmaker I sort of
viewed that line of dialogue as it
direct
I don't know knock at the bureaucratic I
feel like these kinds of movies and
especially Michael Bay's movies always
portray the non soldier diplomat guys as
bumbling idiots or people who are no not
with the program and it's always the
soldier types the strong you know loner
types that are really getting it done
man so that's kind of what I took from
that and less of us sort of like how
Washington is truly messed up and more
dislike these dudes puttering around
they don't know what it's like out here
on the [ __ ] have you forgotten how much
Roland Emmerich's seems to not like the
White House yeah yeah he blew it up and
Independence Day yeah it gets totally
assaulted all over White House - he
doesn't like the White House no so I
feel like it's kind of weird for him to
make political beats I'm just going off
his past works you know yeah Statue of
Liberty's constitute or but that's a lot
of disaster movies he's done half of the
disaster movie yeah yeah I just assume
he doesn't like America absolutely
destroying the world but it's primarily
America he's focusing on destroy no he's
just trying to top himself each and
every T is his own competition now you
know especially now that Michael Bay is
I don't know what's going on with him
he's trying to take the reins back of
transformers
well guys what do you think of the movie
Midway are you excited for it
you know these I just really think after
Dunkirk they should have done a little
more practical well yeah especially
since there's so much aerial fighting
and Dunkirk and the most realistic way
yeah I mean I don't like crazy elaborate
severn like I don't think that's how it
was a little bit more practical look II
know yeah it's this weirdly picturesque
but very it looks like sky captain in
the world yeah yeah yeah it's like it's
got that old-time imagery and it is
picturesque in its own way but it feels
very juiced up and effects-heavy it
feels very glossy in a way that doesn't
feel real yeah yeah so for a war movie
that's a little bit of an odd flavor but
I mean this is gonna be like a mass
appeal pg-13 war movie I would imagine
alright guys well you can subscribe to
the rail rejects click that notification
bell you check us out on patreon where
we do weekly Q&A Stevie show reactions
stream along some of those shows have
reaction highlights included he does
music video coverage weekly and now
let's even paid for the day shout out to
a man named duck MIDI duck MIDI pledge
first shout out and as you guys know I
like to give very personal shout outs
after getting to know said patron inject
duck hasn't gone him back to me and I
noticed this is the best way to get a
hold of someone who hasn't message
you've been a while so you can give them
a proper shoutout duck medium or like
duck the G it's usually followed with
some kind of excuse okay I don't get my
messages I'm busy I have a job I have a
job which is valid even though I'm
totally mocking you it's valid it's
completely valid but usually an insult
will get your attention and the insult
is all in a form of satire I have to
acknowledge that because I'm sure one
down
so suck a duck suck a duck suck a duck
Mindy suck me duck
me duck suck me duck and hopefully you
now know that I've been waiting to hear
back from you yeah and I could get to
know who you really are send us some
duck pics